sorry sorry
[Musik]
also sorry aber das schmeckt echt geil
einfach
so Winter Apfel
[Musik]
ich Klatsche wieder
hallo zusammen heute gibt es mal wieder
ein apfelrezept ich habe mir was richtig
ich glaube jetzt wieder das ist so mein
neues Ding mein altes neues Ding noch
mal hallo zusammen heute machen wir
einen Apple Butter Cheesecake no Base
ist ein amerikanisches Rezept und ich
habe mir gedacht wieso mache ich das
jetzt nicht einfach weil es ist total
unbekannt in Deutschland und dabei ist
es so cool diesmal ist es so dass nicht
Äpfel irgendwie klein geschnippelt in
den Teig oder auf dem Boden kommen
sondern wir machen Apple Butter also
Apfel Butter die aber wiederum nichts
mit Butter zu tun hat also im Prinzip
wird ein apfelpüree Apfelmus Apfelmus
gekocht und so lange eingekocht bis es
so eine buttrige Konsistenz bekommt und
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt erstmal die
Äpfel und ähm schäle sie ihr könnt gerne
säuerliche Äpfel nehmen das passt dann
einfach besser geschmacklich
und aber süße passen auch bei diesem
Rezept also da brauchte ich gar keinen
Stress machen und genau die werden
gleich geviertelt bzw in kleine Stücke
geschnitten so durch heute also die
Äpfel werden in kleine Stückchen
geschnitten und dann geben wir sie mit
etwas Wasser und Zimt in den Topf
[Musik]
ich habe heute Zimtstangen mit dazu
gegeben wenn ihr die nicht da habt oder
ihr habt zum Pulver da könnt ihr auch
das Pulver dazu nehmen das ist gar kein
Problem und jetzt lasse ich das einfach
mit offenem Deckel also nicht
geschlossen erstmal ca 30 bis 40 Minuten
einreduzieren und weich werden und dann
geht's weiter aber wir nutzen jetzt
natürlich die Zwischenzeit und machen
schon mal unsere unsere Basis quasi und
die besteht aus Keksen und verlassene
Butter ich nehme heute hier die Dinkel
Kekse wir können noch Butterkekse nehmen
ihr könnt auch Kakao Kekse nehmen also
alles an trockenen Keksen die es gibt
und jetzt nehme ich mir einmal die
Butter und davon schneide ich mir was ab
und lass sie dann in der Mikrowelle bei
geringer Wasser schmelzen also immer
schön Auge drauf haben sonst platzt euch
die Butter und dann müsste alles sauber
machen
[Musik]
so im nächsten Schritt dann einfach die
Kekse fein mixen das ist mir hier der
Akku leer gegangen jetzt warte ich nur
fünf Minuten dass er auflädt und kann
aber in der Zwischenzeit hier schon ein
bisschen umrühren ich kenne das von
früher da habe ich immer wenn ich
Apfelmus gemacht habe oder Apfel
eingekauft
genau ich kenne das von früher also von
meinen alten Töpfen war das immer so
dass es unten ein bisschen angepappt ist
wenn ihr zum Beispiel meine habt ja es
ist ein bisschen Schleichwerbung aber es
ist ist Fakt dass ihr da ein bisschen
weniger umrühren sollt je nachdem welche
Töpfe und Pfannen ihr habt immer wieder
umrühren also bei mir braucht ihr das
halt einfach nicht weil nichts anpackt
aber es kann sein daher immer wieder ein
Auge drauf werfen und nicht unbeobachtet
jetzt diese 30 40 Minuten lassen das
Ganze sollte halt richtig schön pampig
und matschig werden so das brauche ich
aber noch ein bisschen weil die ganze
Flüssigkeit auch aus den Äpfeln so ein
bisschen aufgesogen und ein reduziert
werden soll ich bin bei Stufe fünf von
neun das reicht mir eventuell könnt ihr
auch auf 6 von 9 gehen so und wenn mein
Akku hier aufgeladen hat dann machen wir
weiter mit den Keksen
[Musik]
zur Butter habe ich jetzt mit zu den
Keksen gegeben und die gut miteinander
verrührt und jetzt benötigen eben eine
hübsche Tortenplatte und ich gebe jetzt
einfach so ein cakeboard unten drunter
habe ich jetzt zwei Seiten Gold und
Schwarz nämlich die schwarze Seite nach
oben und habe mein Tortenring auf 22 cm
eingestellt so ihr könntet auch 20 cm
nehmen falls irgendwie gerade kein
Tortenring da habt aber dafür 20 cm
Springform das würde auch gehen dann ist
einfach alles ein bisschen höher das ist
bei Norbert Torten immer so
so entspannt dass man da einfach ja
diese 1 2 cm da variieren kann
hier raus und dann werde ich das einfach
am Boden flach andrücken und einen
kleinen Rand hochziehen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier den Boden noch
mal richtig schön flach angedrückt der
Rand ist ich lese mal kurz ab da 3 cm
hoch und das finde ich reicht auch
vollkommen und jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach das cakeboard hier runter und
gibt das bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in
den Kühlschrank denn dann wird die
Butter schön fest und alles sitzt halt
noch mal gut und wir machen eine
Zwischenzeit die Creme schauen aber auch
noch nach unseren Äpfel was die so
machen also bis gleich
so mein Apfelmus sieht schon ein
bisschen dunkel aus es hat jetzt so eine
goldene so eine dunkle goldene Farbe
angenommen es ist aber noch lange nicht
so weit denn jetzt muss ich erstmal die
Zimtstange rausnehmen ganz am Ende
schmecke ich noch ab wenn wir das nicht
zimtlich genug ist dann gebe ich einfach
noch mal ein bisschen Zimt Opera ein
bisschen zum Pulver mit dazu ich püriere
das ganze jetzt noch es ist zwar schon
sehr fein sehr mutig aber so ein
bisschen was am Stücken ist dann noch
mit drin und da werde ich das jetzt
einfach noch mal kurz durchpürieren und
dann kommt das zurück auf den Herd und
braucht dann noch mal eine Weile auf ähm
ich nehme jetzt Stufe 500 also einfach
auf mittelrohrstufe und dann machen wir
weiter mit der Creme
[Musik]
so unsere Creme besteht aus nur wenigen
Zutaten und zwar habe ich ja mal
Schlagsahne die schlage ich jetzt
separat auf da gebe ich dann auch schon
etwas Sahnefest und Vanilleextrakt mit
dazu ich nehme halt einfach mein
Handrührgerät die natürlich auch in der
Küchenmaschine aber es ist ein wirklich
also eigentlich ein schnelles Rezept
wenn das mit der apfelbutter nicht wäre
aber es lohnt sich die brauchen nämlich
am längsten so jetzt gebe ich jetzt
einmal rein ganz wichtig Sahne sollte
ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank kommen und
der schneebesenaufsatz sollte jetzt auch
nicht gerade warm abgespült sein dann
funktioniert das mit dem Aufschlagen am
besten
[Musik]
so die Sahne ist schön steif machen wir
den über Kopf
okay so auf jeden Fall machen wir jetzt
weiter mit
Doppelrahmfrischkäse das ist ja
schließlich ein Cheesecake so gebe ich
jetzt hier in meine weitere Schüssel
zusammen mit etwas Schmand und für die
süße brauchen wir dann noch ähm
Puderzucker das mixe ich dann nur ganz
kurz also wirklich nur so 10 Sekunden
und dann hebe ich auch schon mit einem
Teigschaber und ihr kennt mit ganz viel
Liebe einmal unter die Masse also die
Sahne unter die Frischkäse
[Musik]
so unsere Creme ist auch schon fertig
jetzt habe ich hier meinen Boden aus dem
Kühlschrank genommen und gibt die Creme
einmal auf dem Boden und ich habe schon
parallel hier geschnitzt auf meine
Pfanne die apfelbutter ist auch schon
fertig aber es müsste jetzt natürlich
noch Auskühlen wenn ihr das jetzt ganz
heiß auf die Creme gibt dann schmilzt
sie ja deswegen verträgt sich das ja
nicht so gut da fühle ich gleich die
apfelbutter die apfelbutter ach jetzt
komme ich wieder Flashbacks ich war in
der in der Grundschule weil wir hatten
immer so ein Spiel mit Artikeln und ich
habe mich mal richtig gefühlt weil ich
die mal richtig konnte
bei der Apple Butter gibt ihr fünf
Minuten vor Ende quasi noch mal
Rohrzucker mit dazu oder braunen Zucker
und lasst das dann fünf Minuten
ausdampfen wichtig ist dass ihr nicht so
lange das ganze einreduziert bis zu fest
wird denn das sollte sich ja noch
einigermaßen gut auf der Creme verteilen
bei mir könnte das jetzt ein bisschen
ausdampfen und jetzt verteile ich das
erstmal unregelmäßig auf der Oberfläche
und arbeitet das dann so ein bisschen in
die Creme ein
[Musik]
das ist unser Teller
aussieht
Apple Butter Cheesecake sorry
sorry
da lassen ganz ehrlich
[Musik]
so wir probieren jetzt
auf jeden Fall warum Apple Butters hat
nicht so Butter zu tun haben Sie sich
gerade schon geklärt das ist wenn man
das so lange einkocht
das kocht man super lange ein super
lange Konsistenz bekommen
[Musik]
wegen dem Rohrzucker und ich finde auch
das wirklich die absolute die hat sowas
von zitronisch karamelliges man kann gar
nicht richtig beschreiben
dann hat man diese richtig richtig
weiche Cheesecake Masse
ist cool
dann kommt diese weiche Masse und dann
hast du einmal noch was Festes am Ende
Apfel irgendwie mäßig hast
nicht zu stark das gefällt mir ich habe
auch kein Zimmer
das coole ist ich hatte schon mal ich
hatte einen Apple crumble cheesecak der
wurde auch gebacken und ich finde
gebacken und nobel sind zwei Welten
also eine andere Leute von Kekse
man könnte jetzt auch Vollkornkekse
nehmen die werden ein bisschen dunkler
aber feier ich jetzt nicht so
geschmacklich wahrscheinlich
ich hatte es gerade übrigens nur noch
für 20 Minuten nur solange ich hier
aufgeräumt habe im Kühlschrank also es
kommt ohne lange Kühlzeit aus und vor
allem dadurch also gut diese apfelbutter
braucht halt nur ein bisschen länger
aber der Rest geht super schnell und das
kann man halt parallel machen daher ein
richtig schnelles Rezept schnelles
Geschäft Leute
finde ich auch sehr lecker also ganz
viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und
hinterlasst den Kanal ein kostenloses
Abo wenn ihr es nicht schon längst getan
habt und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten Rezept tschüss
[Musik]